this relates not to not kill anyone yeah
you're right that sounds great yeah
is it gonna show us us to go flying
again that's a weird thing to show us
again yeah this is a segment you know we
actually know what times things are
happening like I always thinking that
God because me mostly on them he could
be yes Noah Elton - yeah that's what
this is they mentioned that before
so it could be like my thinking things
happening at the same time but it's
possible I have recognized the same guy
that's it's the psychotic I think
written visit some people are you
attendant no no I don't think a lot of
information to you I suppose good time
on it sir he's so injured like you tell
all you be remembers those times that I
made him fall and prove you believe that
he wasn't even care no yes that is so
broken and now he's like wait a minute
a little bit okay this doesn't seem like
a good idea Mike I currently don't want
to do it I ain't even [ __ ] dumb to be
perfectly honest you should turn around
put your toe anywhere else and we should
just we should turn around them just go
back on cable car [ __ ] everyone else I
do this you know I feel like you know
we've missed a lot of times but
now I don't really think they're very
helpful the totes to be better class
they just tell you something that they
tell you I'm sorry about in the future
yeah how can a predict that's going to
happen when we've chained when the
game-changer spirit buddy doesn't
understand the possible is that so I
think what it's showing you is if you do
these five things this is my article so
it doesn't it
but maybe the totems change based on
okay probably gonna be picking up what
were you eating sounds only but yet that
maybe the totems change depending on
what taco what staff anyone possibly
take yeah like I just go on and he also
has you know what let's look through
because we didn't wondering let's look
back through our character guides he's
cooking funny yet he's up what those
mean that he's is sudden changing Church
traits relationship service that's
things changing I think that's it
see how there's a white line and then
there's a blue line he's gotten less
charitable
less honest more funny more break more
romantic more curious and he doesn't
have intelligent fair you know you know
that was something different that was
under different
okay Malaysia just does mystery-man
a feasel things to miss these things
that we've found all of the stuff that's
not yours that we missed
yeah quite a good stuff charactering foe
so it doesn't say intelligently I
thought you listen to her no it did said
that it will no - yeah but it seems like
we are changing him as a person which is
very interesting I like that that's cool
look basketball it's more variety and
it's kind of gross all right I don't
that's too much power I think we don't I
do want to find out more about this guy
that's not so bright
let's send you whatever Idol is tuned in
dogs because remember we told that we
were skinner walls oh yeah we had to
terrorism didn't we know we're so not
know maybe we didn't choose that though
against an option it I think maybe we
chose something else you know we
wouldn't it said we weren't but it did
ask so maybe a direwolf you know mister
so not scare that they hugged my store
us shuttle sickening pass
you look at it I feel like it's you know
we've been playing for a minute now and
that already hasn't been a jump-scare
this is got to be one soon why why did
we want to do for this guy now because
he's just cross and wants to know what
happened to it all um but yes basically
a bunch of idiot teenagers sticking out
their killers just going back and they
regroup with all of them yeah yeah I all
put their information together and I
completely understand and then they can
just sort of say what happen ice but no
my wife have any of that
19:22 the other one was right it was
contained in 1952
whatever that means was made it was
around 29 cities condemned it does not
circles he pirouettes even that
ballplayer you got that down
yeah seriously it's gonna be a chumps
again soon I swear to God
you keep pointing it out what I'm
obviously more people is of what I think
it's yeah it's not a digital camera so
you stopped taking it
picked it up tilted it slightly put it
back down that's totally multi here if
it's another clue who know wasn't we
just didn't take it it's not a detective
it's never like investigating crime
scenes and take things please why is
there a mole here what is it
of course they're looking is this one of
yours on you know he put the Garissa
walls might be their last surviving
patient
stuck with its rider assaulted on what
remembers over silicon read it I don't
see any hot all the way dick price
yesterday in the incident was
unfortunately a Porsche repo
proportionally trespassing
she's a massive building it is big do
the honors I think probably not though
the probably step you go to bed and then
the more they can almost fit another
deadline yes no more
did you see a special expression when
you're talking to one else that was very
good the facial expressions on this
immigration is great yeah but it's
because it's not that much else to the
game like where are you understand me
yes that's not a pleasant noise I'm
gonna go over this right now
Oh
what nothing sir
see he's very strong
he's basically the 30 [ __ ] name cause
why don't you care about that austere
day with a staff with this cop cards for
working the way this looks on this one
it's see how it's changing the [ __ ] with
something that's pending work like that
in lines you forgot not gonna do much
credit point so I'm walking by James
gillies it can't be it is okay I just
want a circle I didn't realize oh oh you
know what it's trying to tell us - yeah
I was
Oh God
yeah this is a very creepy of course it
is what's in that room oh no I didn't do
it yeah of course it's not to do it
why did you want to turn right if
suitcases in fixed camera angles just
don't work very well or something
glitching upstairs
the light was a glitch up there
why are we here because we don't like
doing this like we said she is really
saying about you well that's fun so just
assume that habits or the crow that was
already bad just don't make it popped
out well now he's got a knife that's
great I'm happy about this
I hope it keeps it yeah keep it keep it
on you
I really hope it is it always fell for
you did you seem to be I didn't use
nothing I wouldn't miss my reply - so I
should remind you - just because I feel
like it's uncommon because I feel like
we're gonna have to hide from the walls
when the controller comes up and says
don't move if that happens anytime soon
the boys may be perfectly still and I'm
not gonna breathe we need to be still
yeah why it'll compensate don't move I
don't know if that's gonna happen again
I just feel like it might and that it is
kid stuff
that means we have to not move the
controller well they're Reds you have to
this - yeah you as well what
any movement might bump it a little bit
just be still and I'm not going to talk
okay
okay if that happens they might not even
happen here I just for some reason we
haven't seen that future
for a while I feel like it's a bit more
like the same skeleton I think every day
like a long before April update you
better keep skeletons around though they
might want to know the sideburns next
two o'clock I'm just just talking about
is that what it's telling me to do no
it's cuz I stopped that's why it's a
clock
that's pretty [ __ ] straight oh my god
these camera angle this is making me
vomit out of Devils hello Kim oh my god
oh the bear trap from the trap yes
oh I guess empty all you have to how you
wipe these off oh no no no no numbers I
know I'm a medicine aback insulting you
all right right but it will come like
get you [ __ ] to give up just a small
it's just a cup just a paper cup just a
little place about not feeling that's
good I'm already broke on the bad
traffic side yeah he's got that not
completed easier than equals net what's
up
police looking for the person I think
yeah I think he's just telling me the
other choice so much way we would go it
seems like the same yeah I think so so
the wolf say my name is coming over to
stop strange way to do is above
Blackfeet
well that's that was the you know there
was a place of Italy that popped out the
man doesn't look like maybe they were
experimented on him and how bad guy I
think you're right about him whoever's
in this building is an ex-patient
oh my preferably a shih tzu seriously
it's not Lots for close to the end if
you really knew it's what weapons are
taught me pretty hard to arrest it was
not me to know what she added some
change on that
the questions now no no this is crazy
okay cool and there's another bonus of
life yeah actually more I'll do one of
them which one do you want me to say
this one yeah I know would you do this
doing which you're walking yeah not
really nothing is it something a piece
of paper I don't know the key card or
that we know it just was something we
named her Nikolas attacked by animate
favor lacerations to the throat so I
think we need to give it its light you
take it doesn't want me to
there's a war well you know the clues
might be handy or not well we haven't
really much [ __ ] from them so far but
they might be for later a climate some
really big thing we've just got one it
is still nothing
yeah this certainly looks good yes okay
woods or blackness a jump-scare was it
by nine bodies do not get covered until
six to eight I love to death section of
the intestines kidney and family eating
by the attacker
that's [ __ ] yeah so we have cannibal
sorry all right Nathan Lee I sure know
that stuff's related to God is a man I'd
say so
yeah who somehow is Wolf prints because
so no can they get easy people are why
are you the only new one I should
actually eat when they're shooting is
Mikiko on the upstairs room yeah do we
know each other I'm not sure do you want
yeah sure yeah well we've got good
solution no chuckles really
don't sound system with a quail the
message is supposed to be a change yeah
that's the joke they have a sound system
they drop mad beats every Friday night
look that's why
[ __ ] okay let's say he does why were
you walking your doors
well yeah I feel like Michaels down like
a beacon like that so okay well we're
going our way
we want him he was in his hands his
fingers that's like the riskiest thing
I've done with my can you tell that I
like it
don't defend yourself sir I mean if
there's anybody you can cut your things
a place that has been classes this is
where we started yeah you seen any card
yeah yeah that's convenient comes in a
nice little look isn't this way yeah we
work with you yeah okay okay well strike
out what we do a little bit what do you
do to move to make you stay still kicked
in
why would you approach it back away it's
a good approach I know it's begun but I
think that this door could have just
done it and it has been with other
humans
see you know it couldn't end up with the
next second yeah okay I'm gonna take
this now though so what I want to do I
don't know
to that let me guess will we go in here
gum right I made it through the shuffle
door yeah yeah I need a shot okay it's
just a weird camera they must be stuck
to get in here
well so far this elide stupid yes
there's one big ago there was a baby
that's a gross man just don't eat
people's houses and take their jackets
it was very small it was like yeah yeah
you know okay cool I feel pretty quick
now Mike you you're doing okay this to
another machete
he's got the machete where he's got a
jacket he's got my pistol it's got it's
what I do mo doesn't yeah I can get her
down win it cigar this is to say though
I was in their services this guy who was
following us I don't know maybe it's not
there can't be no what was just ripped
through by it was it this guy I think
they were experimented on to make him
look [ __ ] up I think this guy is gonna
look like the dead bodies and walk so
maybe it was him that pulled her through
I don't know I don't know what pulled
her through I'm this guy was no one just
died - there's something straight ahead
of them leaving the top of that no let
me tell you okay Oprah so I don't around
it it's authentic yeah yeah but
pretending I I'll pretend I don't know
anything no that's what I did
done by Georgia spine it's like human
bones
is that what a human
yeah but he could have this anymore
where's Jenna oh he kept about him to
Maggie's well-equipped
she's he's basically Nathan's there's
gonna be like my home he's gonna piss
totally sweet jacket look at him yeah he
kind of looks like you it doesn't be hmm
doesn't got the right today [ __ ] no I
took me a long time to find for that
cosplay yeah oh right - sure all right
this is a lot haven't seen it you know
I'm actually really interested to find
out more about this guy I have so many
questions and must them are not
discussing I'm sorry
yeah yeah let's do it no just open it I
have to I don't waste the pistol on that
[ __ ] ah
all right we still macho
it was here and I tell you know the
graphical route yeah
hmm seriously this is a bunch of ps4
games I do well we have dust particles
so they go so not everybody has done
some video game it is incredible or so
it could actually be so we're just sorry
sorry crazy melons alright good pop
tighter lightning damn
alright there could be some way if it's
oil Antonia I will burn him once that's
what we need to pay more attention with
those things so if we don't live in
light a lighter do the death toilets
show you a way to avoid death or show
you a way that you will need it good
point I have no idea what they're gonna
make a good point I frankly feel like
they just add confusion I don't think
that they're very helpful it's highly
life yeah
often control I'm just worried to give
up TT so I know a place otherwise I
would love to the hope you play I'm sure
you'd be able to control the department
just don't I just get used to the
exactly my grip and since you mostly
play we need a different on this than
they are are we so I don't overstep this
looks like the just move it the totem
that we just saw this kind of looks like
this area that could be way further you
shooting him dumb joke
well but it's also it's not holidays
told you didn't even listen